this is a must-win situation time is
running out for the reds it certainly
has been for them and they felt like
their backs have been against the wall
for a while and hopefully carlos
martinez here
can keep their back against the wall
carlos looking to just build upon his
start a couple of days ago against the
twins see if he can get deeper and
deeper into the ball game and akiyama is
on his way into second and he's there
with a lead-off double brings in nick
castellanos breaking ball that drops in
there for a called strike
and he's locked up and down on strikes
and it brings in uh joey vado
and a fastball and a strikeout that
catches the bottom of the zone remember
he was ejected late in the ball game
last night here is eugenio suarez
and he strikes out the side
as he pitches around that lead off
double he struck out castellanos
[Music]
walked to the young single by goldsmith
walked to miller all loaded up for
ravelo this is game number 40 and this
is at bat number 47 for the cardinals
with the bases loaded and ravello lifts
a fly ball into right field
castiano steal the line with the catch
they're going to test him the throw to
the plate not in time and a run scores
to make it one-nothing cardinals
brian goodwin nobody on two out
cardinals up early one-nothing this is
line to right toward the corner and deep
and it is
gone that's a home run off the foul pole
looked like down the right field line
and brian goodwin has his fifth home run
of the year this one ties it up at one
well and hopefully this is a sign for
the reds here that anytime carlos
martinez is going to try to go up with
his fastball they're going to do some
damage first and second now here's wong
fly to left first time up over one
up the middle base hit by one
here comes carpenter the throw will go
into third it's high that allows wong to
go to second it's a 2-1 saint louis lead
runners at second and third good speed
wong and vader and here's paul deyoung
who walked and scored back in the first
and the young hits a high fly ball out
to left
akiyama calling for it makes the catch
vader tagging up the throw to the plate
not in time and that makes it a 3-1
cardinal lead the young with rbi number
19.
the reds have runners at the corners a
eugenio suarez at the plate
first pitch swinging in the air to left
under musty
lost it in the sun
and the reds will get a run out of it
looked like he was under it last minute
don't know where it is
boy that is a lonely feeling for an
outfielder so intentional walk to
mustaccus and they're all loaded up
that's a great advantage
fred's tie it on the bases loaded walk
to tyler stevenson games tied at three
as stevenson goes back to work against
baitery crown ball right side diving
stop mustache at first he gets to his
feet and tags the bag for the out what a
play by mustache at first base boy that
was a bullet the other way too yeah
that's an excuse me bullet first and
third one out matt carpenter's the
batter and carpenter a base hit into
right field the redbirds back on top his
second hit in this ball game and that
makes it four to three st louis
and now they need a two out hit from
bader and around her left side base hit
bader comes through on the o2 pitch
that'll score carpenter
o'neal was running on the pitch and it's
five to three saint louis by two two on
two outs
big pitch in the game coming up into
center field this will plate one here
comes garcia to third they're gonna hold
him there
it's an rbi hit for castianos and a
one-run game well that's gotta be a huge
pick-me-up for nick castiano's
a deep at bat and able to come up big
there things are unraveling here in the
seventh for the cardinals and now the
reds have the bases loaded
inside ball four a hit by pitch and a
bases loaded walk and the reds have tied
it up at five garcia line to single as
last time up and it's a swing and a miss
but the ball gets by molina here comes
stevenson to score and the reds have the
lead
a wild pitch
scores the go-ahead run in the seventh
and it's six to five reds in field he's
drawn in and garcia grounds it diving
stop at third carpenters only play first
low
but picked in time to get the out
another run will score artistini's
aquino is home from third the reds have
scored three times in the seventh inning
jake woodford is in the game now for the
cardinals facing castiano's long shot
center field on the run boehner diving
he makes the catch harrison bader an
all-out dive toward the gap in left
center field turns in a sensational grab
taking extra bases away from nick
castiano's two away nobody on in the
eighth inning
suarez that sweet swing left center
field kiss it goodbye
number 13 for suarez
oh that's a big add-on run standing in
now as a left fielder
now aquino jolts one to right center
field that's it a ton and it is gone
aristides aquino first home run of 2020
it's a two-run home run and the reds
play add-on again
burgles down to their final chance here
with ronald revello
and this should do it
double up the cardinals 10-5 your final
score